apple just ruined the brand new m1 ipad
pros
for both myself and a lot of people
out there and for those of you guys that
watched wwdc
like i did and were really disappointed
there's also a couple
very sneaky things that they included
that makes me wonder will this ever be a
laptop
replacement so let's go ahead and talk
about what they have changed and also
what they haven't and why this ipad
really doesn't make any sense for me
anymore and with that
why a lot of people are saying they are
now going to be returning their
m1 ipad pro now then when ipad pro
is arguably the biggest leap in ipads
ever
obviously it is the best ipad ever made
but the jump that we got
with this new m1 chip added is just
mind-blowing it completely shocked us
when apple announced it
in multiple ways but the biggest one is
just that m1 chip that is designed for
their desktops now because these tablets
are so incredibly thin
we for sure thought that the performance
is not going to come
anywhere near an m1 macbook pro
and that they are going gonna thermal
throttle quite a bit so we gave you guys
estimates on the performance but when we
actually got them in and we tested it
we were just shocked by how well they
performed
and how little thermal throttling there
was in such a thin
chassis and since they're using the m1
chip of course you have eight gigs of
ram at base which is crazy for a tablet
already at least an ipad
and up to 16 gigs at the high end and up
to two terabytes of
ssd that is extremely fast way faster
than
before and you can get all of that even
on the 11 inch which comes at a base
price of
just 800 bucks and on top of that you
factor in having
a really nice sharp colorful display
great quad speakers that this one sounds
actually better
than the macbook pros you add in an
awesome
front camera we have rear cameras on the
back which you don't get on a macbook
you can use the apple pencil as well and
the base 600 nits of brightness
are about one to two hundred minutes
brighter than a macbook
not even including the xtr display and
then you grab the xdr display and the
larger model right here
where that screen is just so amazing
when you're watching movies
with deep blacks it just looks
stunningly good so you take
all of that you add that value then you
get yourself
a magic keyboard that works incredibly
well although it is expensive
or with that now you can get something
like this bridge keyboard that just came
in
a 250 for this larger model 100 less
than apple's option
and it literally turns it into something
that looks
like a macbook bam look at that right
there
this has so many people excited about
the fact that they can get
one device one ipad and now have insane
performance of
m1 in an ipad with thunderbolt
built in and they can have all those
extra features and benefits of an
ipad that you can't get in a macbook now
is the time
to ditch mac os in a macbook and just go
for an all-in-one device
well unfortunately that didn't happen if
you guys watched our performance
comparison
in things like adobe rush it actually
exported it slower than the
older ipad pro and then all the other
issues that people had
with ipad os such as filezap being very
limited
we had issues with thunderbolt not being
able to connect properly some of our
drives didn't connect
other ones that did connect were much
lower than on a macbook pro
we also found no differences at all
between 8 gigabytes and 16 gigabytes of
ram on the ipad pro
and we did a bunch of different
exporting tests productivity tests
we even opened up tons of apps and there
was no difference at all in fact the 16
gigabyte version closed an app
earlier than the 8 gig version so that
was a shocker
and then we found out that the ipad os
actually has a limit of
5 gigs per app so it's literally hard
cut
all of those issues and limitations had
a lot of reviewers including us kind of
just scratching our heads saying
yeah this thing is insane this is a
perfect laptop replacement
has the performance but the software is
just so
limiting and we're not really getting
anything new and i said that
you know when was the last time your
ipad pro was too slow given the things
you could do
on it the old 2018 version even where
you say hey i need it to be faster it's
all software limited and all of us were
saying
wait for wwc wait for apple to step up
wait for us to get pro apps such as
xcode and final cut
maybe we're going to get new updates for
the files app to make it a lot more
usable like an actual mac
and in reality apple didn't give it to
us and i think the ipad west portion
was probably one of the biggest
disappointments out of the whole show
now yes there are a couple legitimate
cool features that are being added
you guys let me know what you're most
excited for down in the comments section
but if i look at my notes list here the
ipad os
section has literally the least added
new features
and some of the things are just kind of
like why didn't we have this before for
example widgets being able to be
added on wherever you want okay
android's had that for
such a long time that's been a part of
ios before that
or the app library okay i guess that's
nice to have that as well
but it probably should have been there
before we have updates for multitasking
which is
great but it's not really a new feature
they kind of fixed it
where before it was very confusing to
use and sometimes it took multiple tries
now they just made it easier and more
intuitive to use so it's not really a
new feature and then of course we have
the notes feature
which i'm going to go in detail in our
next video and hopefully i'm going to
download the beta
version but that's not really giving us
anything really wanted with the m1 ipads
to harness
all the extra performance and
capabilities that's just making it
easier and better on the software to use
an ipad
as an ipad apple also showed off other
software in this section that applies to
a lot of devices
not just the ipad kind of like they
wanted to make this a little bit longer
for the ipad and then they also showed
off swift being able to compile and
update straight out of that which is
great but people want
xcode on the ipad and it doesn't seem
like apple is wanting to give it to us
and the same thing with
final cut pro i would love it so my
whole
thought with this ipad once i got it
once i used it
just like a lot of you guys is i don't
really need a macbook anymore as soon as
i get an update to ipad west
we can make it be more usable with
external drives make it work remove some
of those limits software limitations for
ipads
get a software that can actually utilize
this crazy hardware
i will switch over i have this crazy
all-in-one device that is good for
everything on the go it's productive you
can do entertainment
play games touch screen on there
excellent machine
all-in-one that's all i need now but
apple obviously
does not want us to use this as a
macbook replacement
and the proof of that is when they took
this thing out and they showed off
the update to where you can actually
switch your cursor from your mac
and scroll it to an ipad that is sitting
next to it
and then do your ipad things on the ipad
and then bring it back into your mac
to do the mac things either the macbook
and then you can bring your macbook
next to your imac if you want a larger
screen
so what apple wants you to do is not
replace your mac with an ipad
they want you to buy this ipad which
this one right here is about two grand
for this package it goes
even higher than that and then they want
you to buy a macbook for when you need
to do
real things like if you want to edit
with final cut you want to use xcode and
other programs logic on the go
and then if you want to do it at home
buy another one it will allow you to put
all three next to each other
and just move things from one to another
and that just has me thinking
wow that is incredible is apple ever
going to make this the kind of machine
that it should be with the hardware
that's inside
will the software ever catch up now to
me
after seeing that knowing that we're not
going to get another ipad os update
for another year is it even worth having
this device like i mentioned earlier
all the things i could do with this
machine i could do with the 2018
ipad pro same keyboard same capability
same new ipad os with the notes feature
this hardware this m1 chip
isn't being fully utilized even in
gaming
in video exporting it's not being fully
utilized right now
and apple is keeping it limited with
their files app and other features
so what's the point of having this
machine and i know a lot of people
agreed
we're seeing tweets people saying hey
i'm returning my ipad
if i have this hardware for this much
money i spent but i can't really make
the most of it
and i still need to keep my macbook
there's no point to having and
personally
and unfortunately my return window
closed on friday so
for anybody that bought this at launch
and got it right away conveniently
fridays when the return window closed
wwc
is monday and all of our hype waiting
for this machine
to become an actual pro machine where
you can replace
your macbook and you can do everything
on it well all of that was just crushed
and i think apple just ruined
the m1 ipad pros they're still great
ipads but they're not laptops they're
nowhere near
what they could be and we guess we're
gonna have to wait even longer
and based on what apple showed off i
don't know if they're ever gonna want
this to be
a macbook replacement just by limiting
the software but you guys let me know
what you think did apple ruin the m1
ipad pro
or is this still worth upgrading from
your 2020 ipad pro 2018
is this the machine that could do
everything for you is it what you wanted
with this new software
or were you hoping for more i want to
hear you guys honest opinions now i'm
going to do a video
on the top features getting into that
with ipad os
so if you guys want to see that or other
videos on wwc
click that circle above and you guys can
help us reach our goal of a million
subscribers before the end of the year
we would greatly appreciate it
and this has been max and i'll see you
in the next video